per tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fuori j oggi siamo tornati su
the jump con un ospite d'eccezione che
stavolta perché qualcuno mi accompagna
sempre lui e quell omino che vedete che
sta facendo la cacca la stai facendo eco
aspetta aspetta ok eravamo rimasti a
questo in questo punto dove io dovevo
saltare per arrivare la chi ci sono ben
cinque blocchi di salto e avevo fatto la
verità ho fatto tutte le pappardelle la
juke solo che no
sono vivo a posto è riportato sul costo
bellissimo solo che non so come si deve
fare questa cosa qua visto che per
arrivare lì ci sono cinque blocchi di
salto come hai fatto me lo spieghi
mentre stava cenno a intro lui l'ha
fatto non si sa come allora c'è un
meccanismo in minecraft è che
praticamente consiste nell saltellare
world era stavamo in due siano de
filippi e il pvp ho capito lecce pivot
più basta a spiegare come hai fatto tu
il re si vende teoricamente saltellare
qua e poi saltare qui sopra è però di
prendere la rincorsa fino in fondo ti
può dare da fare spiega guarda come hai
fatto tv saltellare tra il ghiaccio e il
club capito no può allison e come è
possibile si usa per l'appunto per
percorrere grandi distanze e einstein
non ci si arriva
hanno forse ho capito a basto io faccio
così faccio così c'è una tanica ce l'ha
fatta ce l'ha fatta ce la fa da sola
parte sua morte mi portò carista
ho visto la b sono cagata stavo cercando
di capire come gira remigi roma ci provo
io no non ci provi aspetto se lei mente
io so quale aspettarti per amico sono
forte c'è poi quindi ora muoio è un
casino è però la prova prova però a
morire da bravo la inoltre social penso
check point stava posto da cassano ok fa
in una capitale anche perché ci hai
provato buttati per terra check point
erano state vado indietro scusa io
voglio l'ho fatto perché tanto moriamo
torneo va bene da quello che si può
non lo so però mai prima che ti spingeva
i ma non si fa scale cerca le non ci
sono togliti che non vedo non vedo
va bene così i corpi verdi grazie amico
non ci sono le scale te l'ho detto ce
l'ha fatta
c'ero quasi è difficilissimo e il parco
di fitch e che abbia mai fatto comunque
ce lo fa sì ok tagliano lista in attivo
liste non mi muovo da quando gli avanti
avanti con faccia faccia o le che forte
devo saltano non crediamo non cadiamo il
vero che mi dice non cadere in un punto
semplicissimo quando ne ho passati di
impossibili per ok caicco a posto può
saltare sull'altro blocco vai bravissimo
allora questo è uno slideshow nazionale
poi c'è un altro giocatore check point
di là quindi devi fare così vai sul buy
sul sulla pietra questa qua fra
pietranico la pietra va via e tra i
pietro quello che qua e là davanti
madonna che ma io potevo fare questo
livello da solo era meglio ai ragazzi
faccio io e 3 2 1 ok adesso devo
arrivare all anno devo fare un altro
palco dove vivo qua
mamma mia ragazzi pazzesco suo livello
pre che ha inventato e satana vai vai
avanti
vai sulla pietra indietro ma l'uomo è
facile è facile la roccia libra indietro
adesso indietro sulla colonna la colonna
bravo su questa va intermedia bravo di o
sua colonna guarda dovresti saltare dove
sono io prospetta
allora una strada e quella kylie a
destra che però lo riporta in un punto
che ti prende solo un easter egg non
serve a niente
per questo capo ad andare avanti o
andrei avanti me ne fotte rei d'elite e
io commette un omicidio ma sicuramente
lo stacco tutti secolo successi ostacoli
di the telegraph mentre parla di una
corona mentre parlavo mi sono detto
marco a tutti dei tigli salse e cpu
puglia lopez dal collo prendo comunque
se ti fico una testata se ti si rompe il
naso proviamo quando ti vedo cosa dici
allora allora vai fare la slide aspetta
è che da qui a lì prendi con un pool
pavé giochiamo ruota player proprio lui
la insacca
attenzione
basta sti livelli basta invitare la
scritta di fare così bravo ma non grassi
ce l'ha fatta
check point amico mio però ci prova c'è
massimo calì e magliano voglio d'amico e
allora davanti ragazzi per ora è stato
molto semplice io vorrei che aumentasse
pochettino la sfida perché per adesso è
facile quindi ora la mia mi annoio con
le cose facili capito né di carlo ma
niente la pensa caduto solo per adesso
ragazzi e così andiamo avanti vediamo
cosa succede
io vorrei capire un secondo perché hanno
messo del ghiaccio che io lo odio gli
acidi solo oggi perché invece ad essere
tutto così il reddito nel semplice
semplice sei tu che non riesce a fare le
cose
porcu madama perchè già difficile qua
sta roba
spetta a lei va così qua così bravo sono
forte ok basta basta basta amico guarda
che sopra lo sapete non fare tutto basta
tranquillo dopo ancora peggio basta
basta basta con la punto abbiamo fatto
all'inizio niente non abbiamo fatto
nulla autore di registrazione abbia
fatto niente niente va dal indietro all
indietro vado basta basta
alleluia finalmente checkpoint anno
scherzavo perché devi fare con la
scusante
non lo so ahi ahi appena mai mancare
ovviamente come un po troppo facile
lawrence vai vai vai chi se ne frega vai
vai vai vai è fatta ma il livello di
nava attenzione bravo guarda legge
perfetto ragazzi ci abbiamo fatto la
siamo a livello di lava queste carina
più male che fanno soprattutto è molto
semplice da quelli che abbiamo fatto è
veramente ci vogliono dei livelli un po
più easy perché sennò è veramente la
sanità mentale scende sotto zero ok ok
io vai
ci sono dietro ok if you take two much
justo skip a troppo fa poi fa scappare
vai avanti avanti devi fare ma sei pazzo
e hai fatto aveva tra l'altro è
l'orobica subito che non check point
aspettavo ma cosa vuol dire l'accaduto
vabbè preferisco morire perché l'uomo
stava più acuto questa cosa niente era
un gatto
aspetta aspetta aspettava che storia fa
che storia si illumina aspetta
mamma mia ragazzi mamma mia mamma mia
paura
hai detto maria pia le scarpe ye ye ye
ho mancato un pugno no ma mi hanno fatto
subito consorte prego cosa consiste
questa cosa c'è allora questi blocchi
sono morto quando a subire due volontari
avere moderatamente ok ok no cavolo
porca validamente aspetta aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
il casino che casino vedo cose ok c'è
poi ho visto penso che è d'obbligo magri
mamma mia non è reso silo prove di comic
allora se tu premi il tasto f5 quando
c'è la folla è più utile e più utile
perché vede esattamente dove sei
perfetto vai ce la puoi fare
grazie del supporto prego sono morto
slime altro slime ultimo slime quello
era l'inizio del gioco se ci cani
potresti maria checkpoint il game quel
era all'inizio della ricerca mamma sai
quanta gente l'avrà fatto per sbaglio
c'è un easter egg qua sotto però sempre
ok ma non volete vi sembra abbastanza
semplice
il mistery covello alexa sono una
canzone di vittoria riproducono in
ordine casuale i brani di vittoria da
amazon music
[Applauso]
quindi ragazzi questo era il secondo
episodio di minecraft the jump e niente
ma anche un pochettino cosa è il finale
non manca tantissimo secondo me ce la
facciamo nel prossimo episodio ragazzi
sia piaciuto cosa semplicemente mi piace
questo ci sono state voci di schietti e
che come sempre ci vediamo momento
suspense al prossimo vidor da ragazzo
[Musica]